l'officier d'état civil vient donc de
rejeter la demande de changement de
prénom de lily alors qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde l'appelle comme ça sa famille
ses proches ses camarades de classe et
même sa maîtresse selon le procureur
pour obtenir le changement de prénom
les parents de lille ils doivent prouver
que leur enfant entamé une modification
irréversible de son corps de garçon en
fille sauf que ce n'est pas vrai voilà
en 2007 en vue depuis 2007 la loi a
changé c'est que ces voix là et la loi
permet d'obtenir ce changement de sexe
sans que la modification physique soit
irréversible
c'est pas un cas unique en décembre
dernier la petite stella huit ans au sik
a par exemple obtenu son changement de
nom à l'état civil est déjà merci lily
d'être là merci à toi si en temps de te
vois ça fait longtemps qu'on voulait
soir tous les deux c'est vrai on est
content de se voir
bon ben on va se revoir maintenant
conserve une fois on va se revoir plein
de fois tu as été déçu de la décision
pourquoi raconte-nous déjà parce que
j'aime moi j'aimerais que tu nous
racontes aussi ton histoire parce que
voilà tu te sentais pas bien dans nos
scores de deux garçons tu te sentais pas
garçon bref à 6 des patients
[Musique]
j'ai su que j'étais une fille vers la
maternelle il n'est pas dit à maman tu
l'as dis à personne
non tu la garder pour toi tu aimes pas
dit à tes copines au technopole à 10 6
mois avant nous avant de nous le dira
nous six mois avant l annonce est un
copain comme un copain comme un rappel
elle dormait chez un pote et elle lui a
dit mais on a appris que très tard avec
qu'est ce que tu veux dire lituanie je
suis pas un garçon et une fille et
pourquoi comment tu le ressens tu ès à
ce qu'ils aient cessé c'est si c'est
intéressant de savoir comment tu comment
tu l'a ressenti c'est pas facile à
expliquer puisque ce que tu as cuite on
est tu l'a ressenti à quel âge auras 4 5
en trois 3 ans ah ouais et commencer
comment ça se passe comment ça c'est en
fait je pense qu'elle était elle s'est
rendu compte de ça 2 de son mal-être
vers 3 ans à l'entrée à l'école d'accord
mais je pense que depuis toujours elle
s'identifier
mais une fille en fait non le vois mal
un à posteriori son positionnement par
rapport à son frère et sa soeur elle
s'est toujours vécu comme une fille et
c'est à l'école qu'elle a pris
conscience que ce n'était pas elle était
pas ce genre et comme il fallait et que
ça lui convenait pas du tout les groupes
dans lesquels elle allait donc elle a
commencé j'ai été un si jeune âge elles
sont qu' elle n'était pas sa place
rentré dans une classe de 2e année de
maternelle et demandez-leur les filles
d'un côté des garçons de l'autre n'a pas
un qui seront tout le monde c'est
intimidant depuis le plus jeune âge il y
met jamais le souvenir d'avoir été un
garçon family elle se mettait côté
sauter défini et donc mais mais j'aurais
clairement moi comment comment tu te
sens tu es pro tu te sentais pas bien
[Musique]
estelle vous en parlez vous disais quoi
quand elle a commencé à mon appareil
elle a commencé à sentir très très mal
l'année de ses six ans et y en a parlé
vous a dit quoi quand elle m'en a parlé
elle m'a dit qu'elle ne voulait plus de
tous ces attributs masculins
elle n'a pas utilisé ce mot là elle a
dit qu'elle ne voulait plus et voulait
changer son prénom elle voulait plus de
ses cheveux courts militaire et elle
voulait plus de son pénis d'accord
pourquoi pourquoi que celle et bien
parce que c'est dur pour une fille
d'avoir un pénis chez chanel chantier
pas c'est un métier c'est simple et
c'est quoi pour toi tu étais tu es tu
étais pas ta place
ce qui la rendait malheureux c'est ça
c'est le fait de voir grandir sa grande
soeur aussi que s'épanouit comme une
petite jeune fille est de voir ses
cousins et son frère qui vendra dans la
voie où son corps va et du coup je pense
qu est ce qu il a mis très très mal
l'année avant que nous en parle c'est
justement la difficulté qu'elle a eu à
nous en parler ne savais pas du tout
comment ça allait être pressée ça et
puis et puis nous on était forcément
hyper inquiet parce qu'une enfants de 6
ou 7 1 qui explique toutes les façons
dont elle avait pensé pour se tuer faste
et moi parce que je sais qu'elle a et c
est dingue de penser ça à ton jeune âge
tu as traversé une période de dépression
mali qu'est ce que tu me paraît que je
voulais plus vivre comme ça c'est dur a
évoqué pour elle cette période là parce
que en fait le corps humain il est très
bien chez et la période de latence
qu'elle est en train de le traverser lui
permet d'oublier les mauvais souvenirs
ses comptes
qu'on se construit tous en fête en garde
le meilleur donc là en train d'oublier
tout doucement cette phase nous on met
des choses factuelles de côté pour que
le jour où elle le veut s'est replongé
elle puisse avoir son histoire de façon
la plus objective possible mais mais oui
du coup je te rappel de ces soirées là
où c'était dur je restais lendemain près
du lit ça va mieux maintenant lily est
ce que je te sens en pleine forme lâche
200 euros pourtant vous avez retiré elle
aurait pu non mais c'est vrai bordel
soit 700 heureuse tu te sens à ta place
la théorie comment vous avez pris ça
christelle ab comme un soulagement quand
vous le sentiez vous là quand on sait
pas quand on sait pas pourquoi son
enfant dit qu'il a envie de mourir à
n'importe quel âge c'est difficile à 7
ans c'est quand même très très
déstabilisant pour des parents donc on a
vu plein de spécialistes personnes
arrivées à dire d'où venait son spleen
nous a même dit oui c'est une poétesse à
l'aîné avec un speed naturel très
romantique mais ça nous aiderait pas du
tout c'était au point où on se lever la
nuit en soit les que mon mari pour aller
voir si son coeur battait toujours sa
poitrine se soulevaient toujours parce
que pardon ça c'est moi aussi c'est
difficile d'en reparler elle nous a fait
très peur en fait elle décrivait tous
les soirs les façons qu'elle était en
train de au lieu d'essayer de s'endormir
le penser à comment elle pouvait mourir
on voit plein de façon hyper précise et
efficace donc c'est hyper douloureux et
angoissant donc on allait la voir la
nuit et
heureusement elle n'est jamais passé à
l'acte et un soir où on nous a dit
vraiment que sa vie ne valait pas la
peine d'être vécue comme ça on a essayé
de creuser sur le comme ça comme ça ça
veut dire quoi et c'est là qu'elle a dit
je veux plus je veux plus de pénis quoi
et là bas du coup c'est un soulagement
ci dessus on vous donne la clé de
pourquoi elle va mal elle va mal juste
parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à dire
qu'elle veut plus de son pénis à des 10
le vase il exprime toi donc et vous avez
dit quoi et côte mari on a dit ouf on a
dit ouf
et en même temps ça venait répondre à
beaucoup de questionnements en dehors de
ces idées morbides suicidaire lis
toujours une enfant qui a une
sensibilité et un comportement
particulier du coup ça a répondu à nos
questions en fait on sait dia mais c'est
parce que c'est une fille en fait depuis
toujours on avait juste pas vu mais
c'est dingue que lily son jeune âge elle
savait pourquoi elle était mal bah oui
elle avait elle avait trouvé ces lignes
je me suis un tout petit peu à sa place
et je me suis dit que si depuis ma
naissance on me disait que j'avais été
un garçon enfin je suis du mal à le
vivre c'est hyper elle a eu peur qu'on
les aime plus en fait parce qu'on aimait
un petit garçon et que l heure n'était
pas donc on a eu cette sensation que
beaucoup de parents décrivent de de
deuil mais ce question de perdre un
petit garçon mais en fait non elle est
toujours le coeur déclic à 3 en 1
quelque chose qui a fait que tu t'es dit
hey toi aussi lit j'ai compris ce qui
n'allait pas bonne question je n'ai
jamais vu cela
est ce qu'il ya eu quelque chose année
même en particulier ou est-ce que ça a
été à trois ans et c'est là que tu as
compris que tu étais tu étais mieux dans
la normale dans le corps et dans la peau
d'une jeune fille c'est à 3 je pense que
c'est avec l'école en fait non le vaincu
ans après on se trompe peut-être mais
alors donc elle a compris très vite
parce qu'à la maison c'est aussi très
ouvert et qu'elle voit beaucoup de gens
différents et elle avait croisé sans le
savoir et sans qu'on m'attend au dessus
des personnes transgenres aussi belle
c'est à la voix le reportage avec nous
on parle beaucoup en expliquent eux
qu'à son âge elle ait pu dire voilà c
c'est ça que je veux faire mais si
simple surtout et c'est ça c'est ça que
je ressens ça c'est beaucoup plus facile
de dire je voudrais être et d'autres a
rejeté parce qu'on entend parfois des
gens qui confondent un peu les choses
c'est un peu compliqué mais c'est très
important
par exemple on parle pas d'une enfant
transsexuels on parle même plus d'un
adulte transsexuels c'est alors au lieu
dit malpolis en lice c'est toi qui a
choisi ce prénom
et oui pourquoi il dit ça comme ça tu
abandonnes tv bien ça sonnait bien
1il items bien moi j'aime bien en tout
cas c'est vrai alors est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle aura bientôt
l'autorisation de changer de prénom
parce que ça a été refusé mais il ya ces
6 6 à la peine ça ça te fait quoi de pas
de prénom changé c'est pas sympa c'est
pas sympa et c'est très embêtant que du
coup on peut pas faire de papier ce que
vous imaginez ce qu'on compare mon père
en espagne on peut pas prendre l'avion
ce qu'on n'a pas de quartier si on en
avait eu ça coincerait à la douane bien
sûr ce qu'il verrait un prénom masculin
sur ce visage ça ne marcherait pas du
tout donc on ne fait pas les papiers et
par solidarité on les fait pour personne
c'est à dire que j'attends et mélina non
plus n'ont pas de papiers tous des
sans-papiers et ça coince pour plein de
choses hein ça permettrait d'avoir moins
à se justifier au quotidien si elle
avait un état civil de modifier et puis
ça prouverait que que la loi admet
qu'elle est qu'ils allaient bien qu'elle
soit reconnue
et puis surtout le peu que j'ai pu lire
des textes de lois que c'est pas du tout
mon fort cette loi de rénovation de la
voie de justice de 2016
elle est enfin je comprends pas pourquoi
le procureur ne la connais pas cette loi
c-510 et à l'heure il nous a dit des
choses dans son courrier de refus qui
sont transphobes est inadmissible pour
nous et il la met genre tout le long du
texte va cesser d'user insoutenable ce
courrier il est insoutenable
est ce que tu aimerais dire au procureur
mali j'aimerais lui dire
pauline ont poliment way
on habite sur place c'est une question
difficile et cette envie de lui dire
voilà si j'étais le procureur que tu as
dit raymonde évidemment des quelque
chose j'avais 10 ans montrent un y avait
renoncé à personne je suis à dynamo
alors après on se dirait que ces bassins
pas d'accord tu as envie 2e et elle
souffre un petit peu plus chaque jour ça
c'est quelque chose qui aurait pu être
réglé en 48 heures comme dans plein de
mairie de notre beau pays et non il faut
qu à carpentras l'état civil se sentent
investis d'une espèce de mission
moralisatrice où je sais pas de serre
évaluer si le bien fondé ou le bien-être
de mon enfant sans jamais l'avoir
rencontré à l'école ils ont été cool
pour sa moyens alors les noms sur le sur
le terrain les gens du secteur adorable
fait coucou à la maîtresse au cola mais
ne sera pas là demain on vous appelle à
8 heures la maîtresse super tous les
gens les humains qu'on a rencontré super
les juin qu'on n'a pas rencontré qui
envoient des mécènes sur le dance à
l'inspecteur d'académie où ils ont dit
non non à la maîtresse pour appeler les
libye mais c'est dingue que ce que quand
on est en hausse à l'impression que
c'est juste faire du zèle open skies
méduses elle aussi de dieu et s'échappa
fait sans que je sois prêt de la loi la
limitant la loi la protègent elles la
loi la protège elle puisqu'il ya une
nouvelle boîte 2016 théoricien d'obtenir
je le rappelle ce changement de sexe
sont que la modification fille exact
soit irréversible droit commun donc mois
si tout le monde me connaît en tant que
marguerite je vais l'état civil je fais
changer mon nom il va pas y avoir de
problème si sur l'état civil où par
exemple si adam on l'avait appelée bob
depuis toujours cadencé à son frère
jumeau ailleurs exactement sont jumelles
au si on l'avait en or si on s'était
trompé on va dire est que finalement
dans le quotidien son nom finalement
tout le monde le connaisse comme bob
l'album a donc il aurait pu très bien
changer le prénom
enfin c'est une espèce de jugement de
valeur hyper moralisateur qu'on reçoit
quand on reçoit un refus ça n'a rien à
voir avec la loi c'est un dieu ici c'est
lily est annoncé mais voilà alors lily
est ce que tu es heureusement il te
manque plus que ça pour être
complètement heureuse et là c'est parti
c'est juste le petit truc qui te
chiffonne c'est ça pouvoir s'inscrire ou
on veut sans se demander comment va la
quitter après après quand tu auras ça tu
seras heureuse et baby l'océan procureur
1802 et les voilà on est moins drôle il
lui reconnaît pas je suis assez vite
sinon mon cas et j'espère que ça va
s'arranger procure à ses ouailles en
avant un continent oui à l'état civil
aussi longs grecs commencent en avoir
marre des adultes qui comprennent pas
parce que qui a compris chez nous mlouka
away c'est qu'il initia le chien a
compris le chien 48 heures il a compris
ça faisait six ans que le chien on fait
des jeux de dressage et et mélina se
cache quelque part dans aussi dit aussi
on dit va chercher médina et dans la
cambrousse elle part chercher l'enfant
qu'on nomme et quand lille il a dit que
maintenant c'était lilly en expliquer
aux chiens on a dit c'est lily et lily
lui a donné deux friandises et la
comprennent c'est là que le chien n'est
pas procureur c'est ça lily ma chérie en
tout cas on va suivre ton affaire on
espère que ça va s'arranger pour toi le
plus important je le dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tu sois heureuse et ait
réussi à trouver pourquoi tu étais dans
un mal être et ses parents ont été
formidables et kits ont suivi et qu'ils
ont tout fait pour que tu sois heureuse
et ça c'est juste de la paperasse un cd
papier et ça va vite être réglé
d'autant plus que vous avez la loi avec
vous mais oui je pense que ça va se
régler rapidement je sais pas pourquoi
de ce qui est trés interpellant c'est
que d'une ville à l'autre ça change des
sacs sur paris je sais qu'il ya une
copine à lily qui a le même âge étaient
de la même année et ça a été accepté il
ya quelques mois en une semaine
je suis ravi la vie de s'arroger dix
souhaitent faire un gros bisou ma chérie
d'amour j'étais très heureux de te voir
tu es content d'être avec moi je suis je
suis bon en vrai ou moins qu'elle
corentin adultes qui a droit de faire
des bêtises alors sétif ont fait des
bêtises ensemble quand tu veux d'accord
tu rigole on fait des jeux donc j'ai
toujours l'autorité parentale bombe à
travers les styles